the blues on a penalty kill on the road number one
in the NHL that killed off 19 of 20 penalties have
taken 95% just with simple plays like the last
one Kings with a man Advantage early on Cross
high speed Kopitar shoots save is made rebound
by field couldn't Tee It Up Now fiala for dowy
to fiala on the right side taking a look swings
it down for kempe cross sight to dowy handcuffs
him he recovers feeds it around to kempe Kings
with a man Advantage for another 15 seconds at
the goal line Kopitar centers bfield a chance
and he scores Quinton Byfield right in front
TOS at home big body get to the front of that
and darl I think you were talking about it keep
it simple right so you get shot rebound that's
the best chance right there a little bit this
year with his unit the a little bit still
once a whack twice a whack third times a
charm so you get the big body in front third
of the season for Byfield and just as we're
talking about kobitar without a power play
assist he sets up Quinton Byfield the goal at
225 didn't they tell you that was coming you
did here's a steal and a chance score Blake
bazant bang bang two nothing La early
now Todd mclen has been saying about the lazat
line they are money because they're producing
and you can see there's nothing fancy about
that the hack and whack by lazat keeps the
puck in and then you'll see the turnover coming
up Shen has it grundstrom creates the turnover so
it's a forced turnover and Lazard finds himself
in behind broken stick can't control him Blues
gain the line they'll get it in deep with Sammy
bla who's back with the St Louis organization
tough aggressive Winger Kings counter with
Byfield through Center Ice Byfield hands it
off Kopitar to Kee a shot just tipped wide by
Byfield but watch the quick hands here as he
gets to the line it's very difficult to get a
poke and then he has a back pass and kopitar's
right there so that's coming right at you there's
the play Daryl was talking yeah Shen has had a
hand in all three Power Play Goals a gold and two
assists now a cross ice pass and a shot save is
made oh a good save there by Talbot you have
to adjust Watch Camp Talbot here look at how
aggressive he is glove over top of the P picked
up by Shen Shen will leave it for bnic now they
work it out to the Blue Line broken up and a
break short-handed break Kee in DS score sweet
hands from Adrien Kee a short-handed goal three
nothing LA and the kings were extra aggressive
here Kee anticipated but watch this man he has
a couple of stick handles and watch the goal
tender look at b b he loses his balance there
he can't keep up with a puck so he doesn't know
where it is three nothing La here is the home
and wraps up oh big hit gabov on blade right at
Center Ice the fans react here at crypto.com
Arena here is Spence up the middle for dubis
Dubois Chris Crossing to CIA to dubis who scores
oh that's NHL hockey baby great passing 4 nothing
La whoever for the blues here he come three
on two and then you're going to have a player
kind of joining four on three wow when you
have the OneTouch passing like that again
with dub Bo Thomas checked by Moore his pass
broken up winds up to Deno who hands it off
neatly to Moore and out of the Penalty Box
fala a break in shoots missed the net lafier
for dubba back to lafier one time primary
kind of pulled it now CV's backhand bid
is blocked lafier again with it in front it
comes K have a shot never got through to the
goenda hockey club look for them to be a little
bit more physical a little bit more assertive
in their game and throw everything at the net
underway here in the period bich centers in
front tipped on and a save made kyou got a touch
on it Tom MCL was talking about yesterday Daryl
about talo he reads the play as well as any
goenda you were touching on it with Daryl it
is you have such a big lead early in a game go
for the killer mentality gabov backhander arm
saved Puck still alive that's what I like to see
right there from the kings that 131 slow things
down create a turnover Spence for lafier now in
front of coms and a chance as dubba spit in off
the left wing CV as the power play LS down hands
it off dubba moves the middle leaves it for more
more across and a shot just wide or off the
post possibly do know's had chances tonight
battles behind the net with a couple of Blues
but the blues are away with it and they come
to Center ice here is vavich stops up across
to Thomas in a shot save again tbit has just
uh been very square and very upright grundstrom
for lazat in a backhander save loose Puck covered
Bennington lazad is there to help out Blues
working out to the Blue Line shot attempt
from there blocked and deflect in P navic the
other way for St Louis across to Ley jumping up
Ley centers tipped on kyou it's loose in front
still loose comes free Trevor Moore spinning
on a Defender centers in front knocked Away
by the blues and out of the Zone 30 seconds
left in the period shots 2119 La here's fiala
shoots and scores set up by Phil Doo 5 nothing
[Applause]
La I'm sure he'll be texting him later again
the reception by fella but watch quickly once
he gets it to his forehead he's ready to shoot
you talked about it earlier Dar well he's overh
handling pucks now gets it shoots it short side
borzo forced to turn wide inside his line by CV
and now Ley gives it a try checked by CV dubba
with it Blue's changing dubba in shoots blocker
save 200 to fund ball in Los Angeles yeah it's
got to start somewhere Paro lost his balance
then recovered to knock it away from dely but
there is grundstrom who shoots and hits the
post Thomas's pass hit escap Thomas again with
it into the middle to Krug a shot and he hit the
post the inside of the short side post Kyu speeds
in around one man but then good recovery by gabov
bnic sends it across lyia chance save again ver
fiala shot pass tipped wide by England down low
as he and fiala changed positions and now here
comes the neighbors shoots and he scores Jake
Neighbors from the top of the left Circle 51 La
where you have you know not NE I'm going to say
it outnumbered attack you see the pinch off
the board you have the pinch without support
and and the shot is taken inside the circles
and darl how many times we see this nowadays
short side high but when we played I never shot
there no that was the last place you were going
to shoot there was never anything there and
I think just looking at Talbot's reaction
Roy will hand it off and the cheers begin
here at crypto.com Arena Kings five St Louis
one